Apple stock reached an all-time high
yesterday after pre-orders for the
iPhone 10 sold out in minutes the
exclusive anniversary edition iPhone
arrived in Apple stores this Friday but
it may take weeks to ship the device to
customers who pre-ordered on lines
constantine is senior editor with our
partners at CNET he has been testing and
reviewing the iPhone 10 over the past 24
hours here he is with the new phone
Scott good morning show us the phone
good morning here it is okay so it's
like I like the size yeah I think the
size is right and that's the basically
into two different sizes before they the
plus and this basically tries to cram as
much screen which is other my know their
phone manufacturers have done Apple's
doing that now in their own model what
are the other big pluses for this well
it's the extra camera features it feels
a lot like out like a car that has like
all the extra little upgrades is extra
camera features apple's pushing very
hard on true depth which is their face
ID camera so that replaces touch ID that
will also enable some things down the
road for a potentially augmented reality
in your face that stuff's not really
here yet that's basically like little
steps it's really about the screen and
it's about the extra camera features for
a lot of people and we got to get used
to swiping on this one yeah got a route
to navigate you got a swipe right
there's no home button so it changes
things so basically if you're turning it
off and you you unlock with face ID
you're still gonna have to swipe up to
open the phone and there other things
now like you you get two controls you
got to swipe down from the top so you
got to learn you tested the facial
recognition we have many different
disguises how that go actually worked
better than I thought I mean I tried to
based on just changing about the winner
looks at wedding my hair and tried all
sorts of you know shave my beard
different combination shaved your beard
shaved my beard in phases and it
recognized all of it I tried putting on
a fake beard and that work to I tried
different glasses my sunglasses worked
apple says it worked with scarves and
hats
I found sometimes though if you went a
little too crazy it didn't recognize it
which is outside the realm in darkness
it worked it so take it off the take off
all the different facial recognition the
full screen better camera what else so
those are the key things I would say I
would say better camera fullscreen
facial recognition
thousand dollar price and it has another
price and I think is you're already are
dealing with kind of close to a thousand
dollars with the iPhone 8 plus and
that's how Apple does is all incremental
things they're magically a thousand is
different it is but I think for a lot of
people they may want to wait and then
other people may want to show it off you
believe you can get adjust to not having
a home button right now I'm finding it a
little bit tougher than I thought I
think that if you're walking on the go
that the simple click and press to
unlock is really nice and they haven't
found that I think maybe it may be a
future update something is it to unlock
a little faster thanks good thank you
Scott yeah